you
well we disagree with that ruling it's
crazy because you look at it this never
happened to any other president they're
trying to get a redo they're trying to
get what we used to call in school a
deal a do-over and if you look you know
we had no collusion
we had no obstruction we had no nothing
the Democrats were very upset with the
Muller report as perhaps they should be
but I mean the country is very happy
about it because it was never anything
like that and they're trying to get a
redo or and do-over and you can't do
that as far as the financials are
concerned we think it's the wrong it's
totally the wrong decision by obviously
an Obama appointed judge he was a recent
Obama appointed judge
well I've known him and he's been
against Trump from the beginning he
probably wants to run for some other
office I don't think I'll do very well
he's been a loser for a long time
rarely votes for Republicans and you
know personally I think he's not much I
think we've been the most yeah I think
we've been the most transparent
administration in the history of our
country we just went through two years
of Bob Butler with 18 people that hated
Donald Trump there were angry Democrats
as I call them we've been through it for
two years they spent almost 40 million
dollars on it we had I think 500 people
testified
we had one point for 1.5 million
documents at the end of all of that he
said there's no collusion now what
happens is the Democrats want to redo
and we've had enough and the country's
had enough there has never been ever
before an administration that's been so
open and transparent so we we want to
get on what we want to do is get on with
running the country well I put out my
position on the on abortion you've known
it for a long time but I put it out the
other day you have it I feel strongly
about it and all of that is working its
way through court along with the fact
that the Democrats are talking about
third term and they're really talking
about beyond third term and that's a
terrible thing
[Music]
so with Iran we'll see what happens but
they've been very hostile they've truly
been the number one provocateur of
terror
in this country and then you know
representing their country but certainly
our country has been very much involved
because we're trying to help a lot of
people out and I don't mind that at all
we have no indication that anything's
happened or will happen but if it does
it will be met obviously with great
force we'll have no choice say it we
have not instant we've not talked about
it we'll see what happens if they call
we would certainly negotiate but that's
going to be up to them I'd only want
them to call him they're ready if
they're not ready they don't have to
bother well we'll see what happens but
right now we have very strong sanctions
we'll see what happens
I don't know I think we're doing very
well in Pennsylvania we wanted last time
the polls had us losing Pennsylvania
last time when we won and I expect we'll
win at this time because the coal
industry the steel industry the car
industry they're all doing incredibly
well Pennsylvania now has the best
employment they've ever had the best
employment record more people working in
Pennsylvania now than ever before like
in our country so I think we'll do very
well in Pennsylvania yeah they'll appeal
it they'll appeal it's your day off well
I know this that if you look at the
border and if you look at the fact that
the Democrats are really making it very
very dangerous for people by not
approving simple quick 15-minute
legislation we could have it all worked
out it would be great for people
great for lives great for safety and the
borders a dangerous place it's only made
that way because the Democrats will not
approve any legislation I mean they
don't want to approve anything and it's
making the border very dangerous well
we're working very hard and I'll tell
you the Border Patrol people and all of
law enforcement working very hard I've
been unfortunately many of them have
become doctors and nurses and they're
taking people that are very very sick
from a long trek up 2,000 miles and
they're doing an incredible job honestly
what should happen is the Democrats
you'd sit down and make changes so that
we can protect people on the border
[Music]
say it again there are no talks going on
with Iran I think Iran would be making a
very big mistake if they did anything if
they do something it will be met with
great force but we have no indication
that they will so I've given more money
to Puerto Rico then I believe any
president ever they've gotten 91 billion
dollars for the hurricane not only that
our military our law enforcement and
FEMA has done a great job for Puerto
Rico and I think the people of Puerto
Rico are very thankful